hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday a Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Anna just checking in on you
happy new years everybody happy new
decade you know a lot of great things
happened to you last decade all right
maybe some bad thinks when it's behind
you you're now moving on you're moving
on to a new decade you know and you got
some new resolutions you take a long
hard look at yourself you know as you
got in your head a little bit maybe if
you had an edible or something he was
sitting at a family table and you're
just looking at everybody the way they
eat you know and how much resentment you
have for them and then at some point you
know your little inner [ __ ] pot
cookie was like hey man what about you
man
maybe it's not that man right you got
your [ __ ] head and you decided I am
going to make changes for the better
I've decided the same thing all right
and one of them is I'm not gonna flip
out every time well I'm gonna try not to
every time my my computer you know not
gonna call it a name gives me these
little update Windows updates not
installed when it just gives me the
option option of details or install
restart now trying an hour try tonight
remind me tomorrow why don't you try
tonight all right give the give the kid
that enough now why don't we have to
close that again I'm not gonna lose my
temper see this this is me just you know
this is just me clicking here there's
political prisoners around the world
right now in holding cells this is not
something worth flipping out there I did
it see that now when you go to make a
change in yourself you there's gonna be
some pain like there's gonna be some
suffering like right now what I just did
was tremendous you know improvement in
my own behavior with my computer okay
and but there's a price to pay and the
price
to pay is you the listener I heard
nothing funny during that entire thing I
just handled it my emotions didn't get
out of control
and you're still sitting there waiting
to laugh for the first time during this
podcast what I need from you guys is I
need to you guys to ride this out while
I become a better person while
simultaneously becoming less funny okay
there's that all right let's get on with
it it is a new year all right I always
make a bunch of resolutions this is a
year I'm finally gonna become fluent in
French I picked that back up again now
that I've been I got that test behind me
I'm gonna get back in great shape you
know I like keep myself in great shape
because I'm vain as hell and then also
when I get acting work or whatever you
know I only have like seven eight pounds
I have to lose you know these these
actors that [ __ ] moan and complain
about having to be in shape to be in a
movie I just don't [ __ ] understand it
you know what I mean it's like why don't
you put your [ __ ] millions of dollars
up why don't you put that on the crap
table and then watch all the actors show
up with [ __ ] love handles hanging out
every [ __ ] where all right you want
to be a fat [ __ ] go drive a truck you
want to be in the movies get a gym
membership you know go online learn how
to [ __ ] read that's basically it you
know if you eaten right then you know
you only have so many but I will tell
you this though I don't give a [ __ ] what
shape you're in and how much they
measured you whatever clothes they give
you from wardrobe never fit and they
never fit in in the bad way they're
always too [ __ ] small I swear to God
the last acting gig I did I was like
dropping weight doing it and every day
the clothes just it's like you sticking
these in a [ __ ] dryer I'm telling you
they do it on purpose they make sure
that no matter what size you are your
pants don't quite [ __ ] fit which
makes you not go to craft service and
become a [ __ ] pig and I get it I get
it it's frustrating as [ __ ] hell but
you know it's a mind game so you're like
alright I get it okay I'll keep eating
the salads alright but then you don't
let it beat you okay you don't eat the
cake and then you have to go throw up
behind the dumpster alright
I love when people start doing that they
start throwing up behind a dumpster and
then it becomes it becomes somebody
else's fault you know Madison Avenue the
Kardashians whatever the [ __ ] it is they
end up blaming somebody else all right
and that's just not what it is you ate
that cookie man Kardashians didn't make
eat what the [ __ ] am i saving all right
so anyway um uh you know I just was
downstairs they made some lentil burgers
I went to the Rose Bowl yesterday and I
actually I didn't feel that bad at the
end of it then the new [ __ ] sober me
I mean I ate like a goddamn pig but I
just don't have you know a gallon of
booze in me at the end of the day it was
a great great [ __ ] game I actually
believe it or not I left at halftime
which is something I did last year
because I had that tour coming up you
know in Europe I had a long run in
Europe but I got a wife and kid and now
I got away I still have a wife and kid
and it's just like it's New Year's Day I
leave at the crack of dawn or whatever
so that's next year's of playoffs so
I'll stay for the home games but the
years when it's not a playoff I'm not
staying until the [ __ ] end you know I
get home at like you know five o'clock
or something it's not bad I get home you
know my kids been up for like an hour
and you know my wife's been watching her
all day I got I got to be a good guy
here so and I actually loved it I went
out you know we listen to the [ __ ]
game I went back out to the to our
tailgate I smoked a cigar you know with
everybody else just [ __ ] hanging out
Bartnik put on some [ __ ] Black
Sabbath what's that one that starts with
like the bass solo we were doing all
that and he just started [ __ ] head
banging and [ __ ] miming the bass solo
with the cigar in his mouth and a drink
in the other hand and we would just
[ __ ] die and laughing but we had a
great one man we had a great one we
brought the the
GameChanger we brought the flat top
grill and the guy right next to us also
had a flat top grill and I took a
picture of it I was I was gonna send it
to law at telling him that this parody
in the league now because I believe he
was the one that called it the gay he
was the one that named it the
game-changer law I had definitely missed
he's a married man living outside the
city so he doesn't make the journey up
anymore but we're hoping next year as a
playoff maybe he'll come up but anyways
we trying to think there was just like I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened like
the place where we were there was like
nobody there and then all of a sudden it
was just like it was like the hottest
nightclub and everyone was standing
outside trying to get in
it was [ __ ] nuts I don't know what
happened I just feel like there was
three tailgates of college kids and they
were just like everybody just [ __ ]
find a place to park I got the grill
meet me here and there was like there
was like no [ __ ] place to stand
fortunately it created this perimeter
with our chairs but it got more and more
obnoxious the more packed in people were
and there was this chick that came up to
us with the most fucked-up name ever so
I'm not going to say the name I swear I
didn't think it was a real name but she
came up to us and I don't like god bless
her I don't know how she hasn't ended up
in a trunk the way she came up and I was
like this has to be an act she's [ __ ]
with us
she was so goddamn flaky this Wisconsin
fan and it was like we were just
watching and going from tailgate to
tailgate and people started like trying
to introduce him to people and other
tailgates it was like what about Bob
like trying to get rid of her I don't
even know where the [ __ ] she tailgates
you I just think she was just really
open and friendly which is just weird in
a major city she must have lived in the
middle of nowhere in Wisconsin but it
was [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] and we just
kept going yeah okay okay great all
right
all right then and then she [ __ ] left
came back again I don't know what
happened then finally like a third
she came back and she had a Miller
Genuine Draft and she goes can I trade
this for any and Miller highlights like
that's a [ __ ] even exchanged so I
said do I go what are we the Minnesota
Vikings you're trying to make the
Herschel Walker trade of beers here and
she's like what and I go it's a
reference from 30 years ago sorry so she
comes over and then bartnik out of
nowhere
classic him just walks up with the
Miller High Life and just hands it to
her and he just starts waving going okay
bye-bye
he kept saying bye-bye like she was a
little girl and she goes no I'm gonna
give him in a genuine try no keep them
both just have a nice day all right
okay bye-bye all right they gone he was
like subtly turning her around to send
her back all right Happy New Year
bye-bye keep it he just kept going
bye-bye
I couldn't quite hear all of it but we
had two people at our tailgate that
normally don't go and they were like
[ __ ] crying laughing and so I just
started watching them how hard they were
I mean I've been to enough of these to
know that whatever the [ __ ] he's saying
is [ __ ] hilarious it's just classic
bartnick we're all thinking like how do
we get rid of her and he just you can
have both beers and bye-bye it's over
and and Joe came back he was so proud of
himself he goes I was nice I was nice he
goes it was progressive there was
nothing no hot no hostility and he was
he was a total gentleman he's okay okay
thank you bye bye he was talking to her
like he was closing up a store it
reminded me of time on my bachelor party
we were drinking in this bar and there
was this [ __ ] awful band playing and
they just wouldn't stop it was really
ruining our hang and Joe you know he's a
[ __ ] big guy and he was wearing a
blazer so he just looks like a bouncer
so he goes hang on a second and he just
walked up like it with a real deliberate
walk it was a great piece of acting and
he walked up right towards that with
like where we were sitting was like two
steps up so he was head and shoulders
above the crowd he walked right to the
front
in such a manner that the lead singer
was talking between songs and Joe just
walked up and caught this guy's eye and
then he did the rapid up sign and then
just did in a like the singer had this
like what the [ __ ] look on his face and
Joe just did an abrupt about-face and as
he was walking back this singer is
talking into the mic he going whoa okay
I thought we had like another half hour
to play I guess we're getting the sign
to wrap it up and we were [ __ ] we
will [ __ ] die and laughing thinking
he was actually gonna pull it off but
then the part ends like it almost
[ __ ] worked so I don't know it just
took me back to that again but we just
had a great time great food throwing the
[ __ ] ball around there was a couple
like you know eight nine year old kids
out there that were just all about pliz
one kid was like [ __ ] all you wanted
to play defense he was trying to knock
down the balls we were throwing it to
each other and [ __ ] had a great arm and
then there was his check out there we
had a [ __ ] cannon a weird throwing
motion but it was a fight I think she
was a lefty - it was a [ __ ] cannon
bartnik came down the hill he was like
guys around and I see this girl pick up
the ball like all goofy earnest guy
takes off and she just [ __ ] unloaded
if you see somebody plays hoop and they
have like a weird like motion but
somehow it goes in it was like that and
then it got really crowded and then
there was of course the former athlete
dad still slinging it when there's a
bunch of people standing around holding
food and he hit somebody's car and he
ducked away and they had like a real
like the whole family over there it just
had a real douchey I don't know it was
part of it that it respected they were
all type-a they were all super
competitive and they were all just
reaching for the next level which is a
great thing to be but it's all how you
apply it and that wasn't the moment to
do it
they were all competing with each other
of how
foolishly they could throw this [ __ ]
ball around people's like the guy next
to us had this beautiful and a Ford
Raptor that he had in like this military
green wrap that was incredible and a
[ __ ] landed right on the hood of his
car and I was amazed at how well he
handled that I mean maybe because
they're from Wisconsin and everything
but when the guy threw it and hit the
truck I turned around and looked at him
to give a dirty look and he ducked out
of the way you know acting like he was
being all cute and [ __ ] and like I think
he was like my age they had like all
[ __ ] silver hair and [ __ ] so I know
there's always one douche like that but
it's a new day so they don't get a
talking-to they just get to make like a
cutesy [ __ ] face but anyways then we
ended up heading in and we got into the
[ __ ] Rose Bowl I made sure I smoke my
cigars soon enough we got in and we
actually got to see the bands play in
the beginning we got to see the
stealth-bomber go over oh my god and the
lady next to us was [ __ ] hilarious
she was so psyched it was her first Rose
Bowl and she goes and when the thing
went over she goes listen that it's so
quiet sneak up on them Russians or
something crazy like that so I'm like oh
my god this chick is [ __ ] hilarious
and then like that when they went to
sing the star-spangled banner she was
like one of those people that almost had
a good voice but like you know in her
small town she had like the best voice
so she was just belting it out and I'm
like all right she's [ __ ] going for
it and you know they had all these
stupid [ __ ] cards you're supposed to
hang up when the ploy you know on the
plane flies here do this when it gets on
the other side flip it like that it's
like a not doing it yeah I'm an [ __ ]
so I didn't [ __ ] do it
and so the after the plane flew over
they were seeing like the national and
she sang the [ __ ] national anthem
she's belting it out and when she got to
the second verse she forgot the [ __ ]
words and Bartnik was in front of me and
I was like you know just whisper in his
ear go and she forgot the words mich in
bartnick shoulders were going we were
[ __ ] cry and laughing but uh she
ended up being you know really cool
whatever so we watched the first half
and you know was a great gain everything
I usually don't leave games early but
like I don't know I'm just I'm [ __ ]
old now I'm old and I got a kid at home
so I did it
you guys might give me [ __ ] about it I'm
gonna hang for the whole game next year
because I got the I got the it's a
playoff next year but I think next year
I'm actually gonna get like the
flatscreen I'm gonna go in for the half
come out and watch the second half and
and just sit there and smoke a [ __ ]
cigar cuz I got a minute was [ __ ]
great it's really great I kind of talked
to the other guys and they were and and
they were going like dude I've been
lobbying to do this since year three and
it's I kind of get it because the
tailgate is just so much [ __ ] fun it
was like the perfect weather you sitting
on the golf course and all of that [ __ ]
and I don't know that's the part you
don't want yes I always find myself when
I go into the game like as much as I'm
excited that the game is happening like
oh my god that incredible tailgate I
have to wait again for an entire [ __ ]
year all right I think I babbled enough
about that [ __ ] but congratulations to
all the Oregon Ducks and Wisconsin
Badgers what the [ __ ] do they have to do
to win a goddamn Rose Bowl I guess not
fumble little wife I saw a bunch of
people wearing these Rose Bowl champion
1994 which I'm assuming that's the last
time that they've won but I'll tell you
those guys have lost it four times since
I've been going in 2009 let's let's look
it up here oh by the way your Boston
Bruins are playing the Columbus Blue
Jackets today your twenty-four-seven in
10 Boston Bruins who have continued to
win without yeah Lee Mack avoid and
Torey Krug cray Gees out but I think
we're gonna I don't know what's Columbus
1814 today we shall see all right Rose
Bowl winners Oh 28 to 7 [ __ ]
heartbreaker all right Rose Bowl winners
where is it
where
it just give me the [ __ ] list all
right I don't think we need to go back
to 1902 let's just go back to the last
time
Wisconsin want it all right these are
the games I went to USC be Penn State
Oregon lost to Ohio State
Tacey you come out frogs they beat
Wisconsin then Oregon beat Wisconsin
then Stanford beat Wisconsin and then
Michigan beat Stanford that was a
[ __ ] great game
Florida State Oregon that was a great
game watching Jamison Winston it was at
Marcus Mariota I think in that game that
was a great one that was for the
playoffs
Stanford Iowa that was a great game but
I didn't like Stanford's band they kind
of they played you don't have to be
lonely if farmersonly.com I just thought
that was really I thought that was a low
blow they played that for the Iowa fans
I thought that that was a [ __ ] low
blow then USC Penn State again 52-49
that was a [ __ ] insane game Oklahoma
Georgia I believe that was a playoff
right 54 48 and he's all just run
together and then last year I owe State
Washington that was the one I had to
leave early because I had the [ __ ] I
had the Europe tour starting the next
day and then Oregon beat Wisconsin I
don't even remember half of these
[ __ ] games they all just run together
all right let's see what was last time
[ __ ] wood Wisconsin 1994 Wisconsin
beat UCLA and wait a minute they won in
that's weird I saw like three people
were in that 1994 champion they won 1999
they beat UCLA then they beat Stanford
in 2000 look at what
concen all right so that's the last time
they won they won in 2000 just out of
curiosity when was the last time [ __ ]
UCLA was even in it UCLA this is
literally their home [ __ ] goddamn
Stadium has not been in the Rose Bowl
since 1999 and they lost then they lost
to Wisconsin again in 94 ones last time
UCLA when the [ __ ] Rose of Rose Bowl
that [ __ ] out here used to win it all
the time when I was a kid they didn't
win with Troy Aikman and the 80s he must
have last Rose Bowl win UCLA
list of UCLA Bruins bowl games cactus
Bowl this is where they've been in this
century okay they did the Rose Bowl
editing 86 might have been the last time
they wanted what the [ __ ] Jesus Christ I
really liked that program too man I like
that team man anyway uh the [ __ ] am i I
don't have any reads I'm redoing this
podcast a little bit later but I've been
pretty good I started [ __ ] working
out again my shoulders feeling good been
doing that for like the last week and
then today I added some cardio I don't
want to join a gym because I get like oh
I got too much [ __ ] work this month
that'd just be a waste so I'm gonna wait
till the Lord's the end of the month
plus the beginning of the year that's
when they just all the [ __ ] jerk-offs
I just sweating all over these [ __ ]
ellipticals like they're gonna do it for
the whole year and then not so you gotta
wait till like February that's when you
join the gym you join in February yeah
guys when you join the [ __ ] thing so
uh I just did a [ __ ] hike around the
goddamn neighborhood that's all the [ __ ]
I did anyway hey here's a question for
you since I started working out again I
was like am I really just gonna listen
to [ __ ] ac/dc Led Zeppelin Judas
Priest Iron Maiden for the rest of my
[ __ ] life I got a [ __ ] expand let
me let me scroll through some of the
I downloaded all over the years and
probably didn't give enough of a chances
you ever just come across an album that
you get downloaded and you listen to it
once and it didn't grab you or you just
didn't give it enough of a chance and
then you go back five years later and
you're like this [ __ ] album is
unbelievable I did that with a band
called
Angels and Airwaves I think the guy's
Tom DeLonge from blink-182 that [ __ ]
album isn't quite the one from 2014
I went from 2014 the disease might be my
favorite one on that one but just killer
[ __ ] band I don't know I just I
absolutely loved it and now I've been
going out every other day I go out to my
garage the old man with his getting
shaped girl different colored [ __ ]
dumbbells because my shoulders are so
[ __ ] I'm real actually my left one is
but I've been working way I've actually
I think I've worked my way up to man
colored man colored dumbbells I'm into
the baby blue ones the 1-pounders were
pink and then the two pounders were like
a rose color and then I didn't have
three so I had to use a one and A two
and then four I want to say is is that
blue or orange I can't remember but
everything I'm basically working with
this like eight pounds or under because
of the rope rotator cuff rotor cuff
whatever the [ __ ] it's called I don't
even know rotator cuff rotator cuff
yeah rotates bill alright I don't know
why this feels like the longest [ __ ]
half-hour of my life the [ __ ] is you
know what is I think I probably went too
hard yesterday what the even just with
like the food I'm just at that [ __ ]
age I had three burgers I had two egg
sandwiches and both burgers had all the
burgers had egg on them too and then I
had like [ __ ] like 19 of those blonde
Oreo cookies and I can too cigars
you ever just like do something it
doesn't seem stupid till you say it out
loud that is a dumbest [ __ ] thing I
what kind of a [ __ ] way is that to
start your year to [ __ ] you imagine
if I went to the doctor give me a diet
over the last 24 hours
alright I had a - breakfast sandwiches
anything like immediately he's looking
up from whatever he's writing that he
had - what we're on those bacon and
cheese on a muffin then I had three
cheeseburgers with an egg over easy on
each one of those and then I had 26
blonde Oreo cookies I had a couple
handfuls of potato chips another handful
of Doritos I had some waters and I
smoked two cigars maybe I'm sorry - is
this over the last month no no this was
yesterday
yesterday and I I did this all while
sitting outside in the elements I gotta
stop saying [ __ ] like this they're gonna
raise my rates of my [ __ ] life
insurance anyway so now this is like the
cleanse and then today I wake up when I
had smoothie then I had a pair which I
used to love pears when I was a kid and
I don't I just stopped eating them for a
while and then when I tried to eat him
after eating apples for all these years
it tasted weird to me but my daughter
has a book because she's almost
potty-trained and I swear to god there's
a book called it hurts when I poop and
I'm telling you like they draw the poop
in the toilet I mean it's just so
[ __ ] I don't recommend this book by
the way I don't it just
it reinforces the kids get scared like
they're scared to go to the bathroom the
first time but like going number one is
not a big a deal number two free
some out like they feel like their
insides have fallen out they don't know
what's going on and then you read this
[ __ ] book and it's in my opinion all
it does is it just reinforces the fact
that oh this kids scared good I'm scared
too it's okay to be scared but then
they'd like the resolution it's like
basically the kid comes in and he
basically says it hurts when he poops
alright now if he has to poop he tries
not to poop and then he gets a [ __ ]
stomachache it goes on forever so then
the doctor tells some [ __ ] story
about a coyote or something named bill
who when he lived at home with his
parents he was totally neat and then he
[ __ ] lived on his own he lived like
an absolute slob and then again then
there was nowhere to sleep his cat had
to sleep on his [ __ ] head and it said
the mess was like a bully you know
getting in the way of all of his fun
it's like no it wasn't you don't create
a bully a bully just comes to you this
dude creates the mess so then he cleans
up the mess and and then he decides he
should give himself a party you know
because he finally cleaned up his
[ __ ] house has decided to live you
know not live like an animal but then
again he is a coyote right so that's the
story she tells and I gotta be honest
with you as an adult I'm trying really
hard to see the metaphor of cleaning out
your insides and then a [ __ ] coyote
you know renting a house and letting it
go to [ __ ] and then cleaning up I don't
[ __ ] get it so then in the end she
lists a whole bunch of food that makes
you poop soft so it won't hurt if you
take a [ __ ] and in the thing that makes
your poops harder was apples and bananas
and one of the things that made him
softer was pears I was like oh [ __ ] I
got to start eating some more pears but
then the book just basically ends she
goes okay so now you know what to do she
goes I'm gonna call you next week to see
how you're doing and then the kid goes
okay but don't be surprised if I'm on
the potty when you call like that little
blurb at the [ __ ] 20 pages of this
[ __ ]
seyed he's afraid to take a [ __ ] and
then eight of those pages being some
[ __ ] coyote named bill or so whatever
the [ __ ] is and in a messy house they
he decides to clean up which is his
responsibility he still gives himself a
party you get a party because you did
what you were supposed to do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't understand and then the end
they just stay finally just the whole
[ __ ] resolution is is eight don't be
surprised if I'm on the [ __ ] when you
call so I don't know I have to hide that
book because she always picks that book
and it's driving me up the [ __ ] wall
it goes on forever the metaphor doesn't
make us any sense and the resolution
doesn't hit hard enough all right
doesn't hit hard like a hard [ __ ] hit in
the [ __ ] toilet water that they draw
in the goddamn book sorry I know that
was graphic but that's my world you know
that's the book that she [ __ ] likes
right now so I'm going to I'm going like
like coyote bill I'm gonna [ __ ] take
that book and put it in a different part
of the [ __ ] house and I'm just going
to yeah
just every hour take her in there like I
have been and just act like it's not a
big deal rather than reading a story
about some kid who all he does is talk
about that he's afraid to take a [ __ ]
except for the last [ __ ] page anyway
sorry I didn't mean to get emotional all
right we got the playoffs this weekend
everybody playoffs who do you like here
come my playoff pics somebody who leaves
a bowl game early [ __ ] you man I went to
I went to a twelve of them and stayed
the whole goddamn time alright I've
earned it I walk out like Mike Pence one
of the worst staged outraged things ever
all right what am I looking for the
playoff playoff picture here it's
GarageBand
I don't need that ooh a playoff picture
here we go all right AFC wild cards the
Tennessee Titans at the New England
Patriots I say I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say the Patriots win that one
all right we're playing a six seed I had
the hiccups that's from yesterday sorry
nine and seven I should have taken the
microwave when I did that I apologize
and then you have the Buffalo Bills
playing at the Houston Texans now I
gotta be honest with you I don't know
who the [ __ ] gonna win that game the
Bills have a great defense can they do
can they contain that quarterback that
mobile quarterback whatever is goddamn
name is the Texans beat the Patriots so
I want the bills to beat the [ __ ]
Texans all right and then the winner of
those games I don't know one of them
gets to play the Chiefs and one of them
gets to play the Ravens so I would think
the Patriots having the best record of
everybody we would play the lower seed
the second see we would probably play
the Chiefs so that means either the
Titans the bills or the Texans will play
the Ravens next week and that the either
the Patriots or or the Texans or bills
will play the Chiefs because if the
Patriots lose the pages lose to the
Titans then either the bills or that the
winner of the bills Texas would then
play the Chiefs I think that's how it
would work I have no idea and then he
got the 49ers in Pulver's he's picked
the Green Bay Packers my pick is the
Ravens and the Seahawks Seahawks win it
and now I don't know how that's looking
I did not like that delay a game call
that they took all right you got Saints
first the Vikings okay the Saints are
the Saints and the Vikings of the
Vikings it's the playoffs
it's the Minnesota Vikings they're
playing a road game this is a no brainer
the Saints are going to win that game
the Eagles are playing at home against
the Seattle Seahawks Seattle Seahawks
for some reason are a fifth seed even
though there are eleven and five and the
Eagles are a fourth seed that's right
because they won their division with a
nine and seven record now this is a team
that two years ago won the Super Bowl
this is a great out of all the games I
think that's gonna be the best game can
sneak EP come in there with the game
plan I lost a lot of confidence with
them at the end of the 49ers game but
I'm sticking with my pick I say the
Seahawks win that game I like the Saints
at home
I like the Patriots and I'm going to say
I'm gonna say Buffalo is gonna surprise
the Houston Texans I think if they're
gonna surprise him I think they're a
really solid team and they got a great
[ __ ] defense and Houston Texans are
they're just too young they don't have
any [ __ ] traditions of any history of
winning in the playoffs so I think the
fact that they're just in the playoffs
you know all those overweight people
Houston they're probably just excited
they get the tailgate again you know
that's alright okay there you go there's
your playoff breakdown and that's the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast happy New Year to
everybody and oh my god my tour starts
next week holy [ __ ] I'm back out on the
road on the road again Chicka Boom
Chicka Boom Boom Boom I got two shows in
Memphis with the Rose Bowl tailgate
legend Joe bartnik that's on Monday and
I believe we're at the Orpheum Theatre
and then I'm at the Mahalia Jackson
Theatre in New Orleans later on that
week Thursday and Friday and then we're
hanging in New Orleans we're gonna go to
that [ __ ] college Super Bowl game
we're going to the the LSU Tigers first
the clemson tigers how about that yeah
and no I won't be leaving that game
early I know you guys are gonna give me
[ __ ] for that but I stand by the
decision underrated underrated leaving a
[ __ ] game early when you got a wife
and kid at home and you got
i cigar back at the tailgate alright
that's it everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
enjoy the weekend and I will talk to you
on Monday Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 2nd 2012 how's it going
how are you I know I know I know I'm a
day late I understand and you know I
appreciate all the emails I got where
people genuinely you know genuinely
can't even say the word do you notice
how I couldn't say genuinely and then I
tried to play it off by going you know
that everybody Jalen you know just sort
of mutter through that word I can't
pronounce that people genuinely showed
concern where are you built did you fall
down the stairs um I had a I had a crazy
weekend where I was working up in San
Francisco you know working New Year's
for the first time in like four years
because I go to the Rose Bowl every year
on New Year's Day and I'm just like [ __ ]
this I'm not working but how the Rose
Bowl works is if the Rose Bowl if
January first falls on a Sunday they
bump it to Monday because they don't
want to compete with NFL football so
that opened it for me to work New Year's
I'm like why I don't want to fly too far
away I'll fly [ __ ] I'll go work in
San Francisco sounds like a good deal to
me I'll fly out of Burbank Airport this
little cute mom-and-pop Airport you show
up there's like three people there some
old lady gives you a [ __ ] homemade
cookie it's one of those airports you
know the time for God and I was gonna
fly right out fifty minutes I was gonna
land me and my girl we're gonna hang out
the night before the night before right
I'm gonna walk around the city have a
good time get one of their delicious
burritos and I was gonna bang out the
show next morning wake up jump on the
first one smoking come right back to
[ __ ] LA and it would have been done
end of story
so here's what happened
we're driving over right Mike you know
I'm only gonna be gone for less than 24
hours I'll leave the car at the airport
everything's gonna be fine as I'm
driving over to the [ __ ] Airport a
computer calls me not a person not a
representative not somebody with a heart
and some sort of lifeforce pumping
through you know pumping through the
body [ __ ] computer calls I pick up
the phone I'm like hello and it's like
hello William Burke your flight has been
canceled you are now leaving the same
airport 24 hours later go [ __ ] yourself
that was it that was it what the [ __ ] in
there when they wouldn't try to make
leave at 6:30 p.m. I [ __ ] shows at
8:00 you know I can't leave that late so
I call up the cut down there trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] going on so
what do they do they immediately well we
don't have any more flights Anna Burbank
we can stick it down in LAX
what happened United Airlines because we
tried to change our seats and the whole
[ __ ] thing was full okay since when
do you cancel a full plane what happened
huh was the pilot drunk is that what
happened did he knock up one of those
stewardesses is that what happened did
they [ __ ] right up in the first-class
cabin there wasn't time to [ __ ] kids
it's cleanup I don't know what happened
so then they stick me on this [ __ ]
flight out of LAX I don't want to go out
LAX no [ __ ] reason of going out of
Burbank because I don't want to go out
of LAX LAX sucks it's the [ __ ] worst
it's [ __ ] 9 million goddamn people
down there and they all stand there
rolling their eyes at how long the
security line is and then when it's
their turn they're up to bat [ __ ] and
then they start on doing everything that
they should have been doing in the
[ __ ] line you know it's like when
you're in a traffic jam it's like when
you yes it is like this
it's like when you're in a [ __ ]
traffic gym and everybody slowing down
and slowing the [ __ ] down and still in
the [ __ ] down you like what's going on
what's going on and the traffic so bad
you're like I better see a [ __ ] head
lane in the road the level of this
traffic what happens my time to get up
there there's just somebody changing the
[ __ ] tire okay and is this to do Sh
in front of you who you've seen but
looking at the back of their head you
see that just as frustrated you what do
they do they slow down and look at it
I'm always that good banging on the horn
the [ __ ] is rod how did you not learn
anything in this process I do that [ __ ]
too when the cops are standing there
directing traffic after they've mopped
up all the blood and there's really
nothing to see other than some twisted
wreckage right and Jesus Christ you can
go home and watch the footage of it on
YouTube by the time we get home
someone's gonna upload it and you got a
good chance that the person who died was
videotaping it there's a couple of those
on youtube people videotaping racing
with other people they lose control the
[ __ ] car you know like I want to
tipped over and they're sitting there
driving like [ __ ] and it's weird
it's kind of creepy but there's also a
justice to it so anyways the next
morning I wake up and I'm like you know
I off so my girls all bummed out because
we're gonna spend a night up in San
Francisco you know holding hands walking
around you know and now that's out the
window so of course she's pouting cuz
that's what women do don't you yeah I'm
gonna act like I'm four all right then
all of a sudden you feel yourself going
and like like appeasing or whatever
entertaining that energy that she's
putting out like you're the one who
canceled the flight so you're trying to
keep her cool why on the backi ahead
you're getting [ __ ] mad at her like
did you [ __ ] understand I'm the
[ __ ] guy's got to do the goddamn show
what the [ __ ] are you pouting about stop
being mean to me becomes that see she
can't be that guy he's like yeah I know
what some other
chick [ __ ] that we can do hey you want
to go see the broad with the dragon
tattoo above her ass I'd love to see
that movie all right let's go so we go
down the street we go see the chick with
the Dragon Tattoo above her ass right
little [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm watching the
movie that's one of my thanks I like
action movies that have a female a
badass woman as the lead you know I
think they just done the guy too many
[ __ ] times I'm a child of the 80s I
saw it a bazillion times I saw every
Schwarzenegger every Stallone every
Chuck Norris and the Jean Claude Van
Damme every who's the guy they used to
be a actor now he's a cop and he calls
everybody cuz where's the gun cuz he
speaks in like good times jive in 2012
Steven Seagal I saw all in his [ __ ]
movies and you know once I saw all like
collectively those 200 movies believe it
or not I started to notice a pattern and
things became a little cliched so now
they got you know so then they kind of
backed off the badass guy movie for a
while
all right sort of became more about what
the badass guy was saying more the
dialogue kind of badass [ __ ]
Tarantino [ __ ] came in the Reservoir
Dogs a pulp fiction's then I got on
board with that but I still miss just
the regular old ass-kicking [ __ ]
superstar so one day they go you know
what if we made the exact same movie
except the lead was a [ __ ] life and
then you know what I was right on board
it became new again it's like when they
take an old white movie and then they
just make it black you know it's the
same movie except now it's black people
and I'm [ __ ] right in there guess
who's coming to dinner this time now
it's a white
oh [ __ ] it's sitting there watching it I
mean there's only so many storylines
what is Hollywood supposed to do do you
realize how [ __ ] bad movies are gonna
be in the year [ __ ] where the hell
are we 2012 in the year 2100 the only
thing that's really gonna change is the
technology the Pixar the perfect storm
wave you know at that point to probably
have somebody throw in a bucket of water
in your face as you're watching it you
know the movies so good one of my
friends drowned right that's the only
thing but in the the at the end of the
day it's gonna be the same [ __ ] movie
so I go down there I got out of the
little movie house down to the cinema
you know I come walking and I go let me
get two tickets to the the chick with
the [ __ ] stamp right above her [ __ ]
and they go sir you can't use that kind
of language
what the [ __ ] you mean you showing rate
at our movies she goes oh that's a good
point
that didn't happen but I wish it did and
so we got the tickets that go in there
getting a big [ __ ] KitKat we sit out
we start watching the second i watch
this movie in 20 minutes in I fall
asleep not cuz it's boring just because
I'm old I'm at that level all right you
give me a just a half way comfortable
[ __ ] chair and you turn the lights
out I mean that's it sudden my head gets
hey heavy you know I'm like a [ __ ]
toddler I can't hold his goddamn head up
or maybe an infant I don't know how many
kids you know you know when the head
feels like a nerf basketball at that age
all right if you don't hold them up the
[ __ ] little baby esophagus starts
curving like a question mark right that
age that's what I feel like so does
anything make your girl matter than if
you fall asleep in a movie are you
sleeping
no no I'm just really thinking about the
plot it's so deep man this movies so
heavy so I thought the movie was all
right it was all right and the chick was
badass and I don't know if they were
actually [ __ ] if they weren't
actually [ __ ] that girl should get an
Academy Award for the best miming of
intercourse that I've seen I mean I
don't know that two people actually
[ __ ] could have moved better than the
way this chick was moving it's
ridiculous and there's been a couple of
movies too where like people just are
now sticking their faces between chicks
ass cheeks and I don't know if it's
because we've all watched so much porn I
mean that's [ __ ] insane you said
they're looking at going like alright
maybe she's got some sort of special
effects on these on I don't know what
but his nose is up against her [ __ ]
hoo-hah there's no way it isn't it's no
way it is so anyways we watch that
[ __ ] movie and you know we come out
of there
my girls all happy again I go look you
know we're gonna take plane out tomorrow
morning out of [ __ ] LAX we'll be up
there and nothing flat you know I paid
for the hotel room for two nights
instead of one that way when we land at
11 in the morning I could just [ __ ]
walk in there or 10:00 in the morning I
can just walk right in and check it we
don't have to wait
sure I'm sorry you can't check in and
kill teenie afternoo and then you have
to check your bags and wander the city
like a homeless person you know I'm
trying to put a rush on it but go [ __ ]
yourself you know so anyways wake up we
wake up the next morning and oh by the
way the United Airlines lady had a
[ __ ] attitude with me cuz she goes
you're all confirmed out of LAX I go
wait a minute wait a minute what about I
thought we had Burbank she does sir you
just confirmed that and I said a
sweetheart easy with the attitude you
just gave me three different flights one
of them I was going to Phoenix first
alright you're playing flight three-card
Monte over the goddamn phone here I
don't need the attitude and she said I'm
sorry sir I think I Happy New Year and I
look you know and then I thought I hung
up the phone but I didn't and I go to go
to my girl Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like pushing buttons I don't know I
don't know if she was still listening to
what whatever back to the story so we
wake up the next morning okay whatever
we've been delayed 12 hours let's go
down to [ __ ] LAX standing 800 deep
line to go through to go in a [ __ ]
50-minute flight all right we go on
check our flight our flight is delayed
an hour and we still don't have any
seating assignment and I was like you
know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] this were
driving up all right
well [ __ ] dry don't give a [ __ ] that
it's five and a half hours we're driving
up and and then instantly all the stress
of the day went away because now my
destiny was back in my own hands okay I
didn't have to go down there and plead
with them to get me a [ __ ] seating
assignment you know like I was in
[ __ ] Vietnam trying to catch that Lao
that's such a hacky reference at this
point like I was in Laos trying to get a
fish taco on [ __ ] dictator Day times
you know I got to read more that's what
it is um like I read you know what if
Charlie Sheen made a movie about [ __ ]
Laos than I would have had that [ __ ]
reference for you
wow this podcast just died let me try
and resuscitate it here so anyways so we
end up we end up [ __ ] driving up
there we have a great goddamn time I'm
driving up in a Ford or [ __ ] Ram 1500
pickup truck that I rented for the
[ __ ] grand
you know [ __ ] cruised up in that
thing cruised up wouldn't like [ __ ]
90 the whole way anytime you see one of
those signs that says you know you're in
the middle of nowhere and it says
warning your speed can be is being
tracked by aircraft it isn't all right
what do you think there's somebody up
there in a biplane with [ __ ] a scarf
flapping in the wind okay from that tree
to that tree was a fight
which carry the one [ __ ] yourself has
anybody ever gotten a ticket got some
guy in an airplane figured out that they
were going 70 in a 55 huh did you well
send me an email about it cuz I'm not
reading it yeah so I just drove 90 the
whole [ __ ] way up ended up getting up
there at like I think like 12 noon so
it'd only take me took me as far as like
time goes and only took like an extra 60
minutes because you know you got to get
down there an hour and a half [ __ ]
early the flights an hour and a half
that's three [ __ ] hours then you got
a deal with another hour getting back
from the thing that's that's right there
that's four and a half hours was it was
that for whatever took me another two
hours [ __ ]
you know but I had a nice big seat I
didn't have some fat [ __ ] sitting next
to me and if I wanted to pull over and
take a piss at a Dairy Queen I could and
you know what I got to see as I drove I
got to see America you know I got to
read these signs stop the Congress
created Dust Bowl and I was like what
the [ __ ] is that
and then I had something to do what
they're not giving him enough water up
there and I was like oh there's
something else that I can read that's
gonna scare the [ __ ] out of me why are
they [ __ ] with the food supply
so anyways Jesus Christ where the [ __ ]
am I so we go up we go I do the goddamn
show and then I Drive back and
everything was [ __ ] great and then
what then what it's I get the whole day
off and I just start preparing for the
Rose Bowl the [ __ ] granddaddy of them
all we're doing it up right this year we
had the four-door pickup truck we had
two grills we had marinated steaks and
we had like 36 [ __ ] Budweiser's two
big things of Crown Royal and some
Jameson and ketchup right ready to
tailgate
cuz we pick everybody up it's going down
like [ __ ] one of those Chuck Norris
movies when he's picking up all his
Special Forces right [ __ ] three-deep
driving over the [ __ ] Joe Bart Nick's
Joe bartnik the heart and soul of our
[ __ ] tailgate
all right we pull up I call him he tells
me throughout his [ __ ] back all right
boy like I this is bartnik he's gonna be
fine he comes walking out of the side of
his building I swear to God you would
have thought that he was walking on
broken glass and we see him alright our
enforcer hobbling up the goddamn Street
and it just took the wind out of all of
our sails you know what I mean it's like
you're on the Celtics and Larry can't
play and he got the Lakers that day you
know and he comes walking up and we're
all legitimately concerned about him
because we can tell he's in a ton of
pain and he opens the door ever so
gingerly before any of us can speak he
goes you know what boys you play her
today and you know why and then he
screams baby and then [ __ ] makes a
fist and starts punching everybody
instead of doing a fist bump he's
punching your fist and then we knew it
was on you know it's like somebody took
away Christmas and then all of a sudden
they go just [ __ ] with you and they
flipped the lights back on and I gotta
tell you something every year I tell you
guys all these hilarious [ __ ] stories
at the Rose Bowl but this year we drank
so much I really can't remember anything
I can't remember a [ __ ] thing all I
remember was we pulled up they put us on
you know you're on a golf course one
this grassy knoll and law heads telling
ya you want to [ __ ] pull up a little
bit more we're like nah nah we'll put
through the tailgate in front of the
truck all right and everything was great
we set up shop everything was iced down
and I opened that first Budweiser huh
the king of beers that the granddaddy of
them all and I drank it like it was
nothing and I was like wow that went
down really smoothly and then I saw the
Crown Royal sitting there and I just
said eh I go who wants to heat her and
that's really the last thing that I
vividly remember
I had no nourishment in my stomach I had
a beer and I poured basically a
quadruple this brought maybe a triple
because there was a lot of ice in there
and I that I had both of those before I
had my [ __ ] omelet and it's weird
like I don't not remember the tailgate
but I don't really remember it we were
there at 8:30 the game didn't start till
2:00 and it I felt like I was tailgating
for like 20 minutes that's all I
remember
I remember bartnik at one point we were
unloading and all of a sudden II just
yells at the top of his lungs he goes
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the it
basically scared the [ __ ] out of 90% of
the people around our tailgate which was
great he basically he basically pissed
on our whole territory and nobody [ __ ]
with us for the rest of the time what
else happened I remember this [ __ ]
hot chick came over this Wisconsin I
know right hot chick from Wisconsin who
would have thought you know they usually
look pretty banged up if they [ __ ]
banged up out there you know they're
goin to school and they're working on
the farm just taking all four [ __ ]
seasons right to the face you know the
side order of cheese I mean that's hard
living up there look at those people
they don't know any better look at the
Green Bay Packers
is there any [ __ ] logical reason why
they're that close to the Arctic Circle
and they still play the game outside I
mean I feel it should be played outside
abso-fucking-lutely
you know but the level of [ __ ] that
are in this country now I can't believe
they having you know we need some shitty
retractable dome they know they sit
outside showing up in ear muffs and a
[ __ ] fedora just like Vince Lombardi
they don't know any better it's not
because they're tough they don't [ __ ]
know any better that's why they eat the
way they eat up there they don't know
any [ __ ] better you know it's the
funniest [ __ ] thing is bringing up
any sort of healthy eating to somebody
from Wisconsin they immediately just
[ __ ] wrinkle
up that goddamn noses you know and it's
not even like oh that's gay I'm not
eating that way like they literally
eating in a healthy way
disgust them they react to vegetables
the way most people react to like
sardines
so this [ __ ] hottie shows up right
she's got the you know they got the
badge of red and white and [ __ ]
overalls she's wearing a pair of those
with nothing but it's like a [ __ ] tube
top underneath you know a little
raven-haired cutie with brown eyes skin
all [ __ ] tan a little sexy tattoo on
the [ __ ] side and she comes walking
over it goes hey you guys want to do a
dirty sanchez I'm thinking what the [ __ ]
is a dirty see I mean I I've heard of
this the the the sex one what are you
talking about and she had some tequila
and she had a and then she had this big
jar of pickles so they're [ __ ] doing
shots a tequila and right after you
drink pickle juice I know that that
sounds disgusting I can tell you was the
greatest [ __ ] thing ever I don't care
how hard core you are there's no way to
drink tequila without making that I just
drank some tequila face and I took a
shot at the tequila and like an [ __ ]
I was so drunk I didn't get how she
explained it to me I was trying to reach
in and take out a pickle who's gonna eat
it she's gone no no you drink you drink
the juice I'm like oh oh that's how you
do I let me try it again so I did
another shot and then I drank the pickle
juice and I gotta tell you who's [ __ ]
tremendous you know you take a shot at
tequila and you feel like somebody
punched you in the throat and then you
drink that room-temperature pickle juice
and it's like someone gives you a hug
like I sorry about that I I know that
was your larynx and that probably hurt
you know so I learned that so there you
go that was the problem
I was drinking Budweiser's I was I was I
don't know I don't even know what the
[ __ ]
kappa i remember standing a line at one
point going is this the line of the
bathroom and they were like no it's the
line to the gift shop and there was this
giant building with this huge sign that
said rose bouquet that guy the guy i
asked had that please don't punch my
wife or scare my children look on his
face and i was like wow i think i'm
really [ __ ] up
and i don't know and then i went to the
game I was completely [ __ ] wasted but
I remember the entire game it reminded
me the old like San Diego charger of
Miami Dolphins matchups back in the day
when there was just like no [ __ ]
defense the [ __ ] was the final score was
like 45 38 and I was so bummed out when
that dude didn't spike the ball in time
you know cuz I was like here we go we're
gonna he's got one shot going down you
know in the end zone one shot in the end
zone for the granddaddy of them all
let's see it then they tweet and we're
all sitting there like you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me and then they go to
do a review of it I'm thinking in my
[ __ ] head there's no goddamn way
they're gonna let this [ __ ] great
game end on that [ __ ] play alright
and then they come out and they go yeah
it's over they shoot off confetti it's
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] awful so that
we wander out to the truck back out in
the parking lot we fired up the grill
and people started drinking again I
tapped out cuz I had to drive and that
was basically the Rose Bowl this year
I'm sorry I usually have a bunch of
funny stories by honestly I can't
remember I was so [ __ ] excited that
we had all this food next year I'm gonna
eat a little something first and I'm
gonna start with beers okay and I'm
gonna not go to the whiskey for the
first couple hours I think that that was
the big mistake we were bait it was like
a 1 round knockout that's what our
tailgate but first we were like out on
our
for the final [ __ ] 11 rounds I
remember one point talking to somebody's
wife saying you know cuz you know the
wife of course didn't want him to go you
know I can't tell it's cuz you know
probably cuz she was smart and I just
remember talking to her telling her what
a great man her husband was and saying
hey he's over there right now sitting
down just enjoying the sunshine and he
and he he wasn't remotely doing anything
like that sorry sorry smoking a [ __ ]
cigar yesterday - that was another thing
you know and I was so drunk I kept
forgetting it was in my hand so then it
would go out and then I have to relight
it and I was too drunk to [ __ ] you
know do them get it to go and I was
actually inhaling so I I don't know yeah
we had for Ricky Ricardo's [ __ ] smoke
those up and I remember getting a
pretzel I'm just gonna piece this whole
[ __ ] thing together like the guy who
played Han Solo you know with the
one-armed murderer the fugitive the [ __ ]
happened I remember standing in line and
getting a pretzel and I go you want salt
or no salt I go I'll take salt and it
was so [ __ ] salty I just I just
member just flicking the [ __ ] salt
off and it was getting all over my shirt
because I'd already put mustard on it
the [ __ ] is wrong with me well this is
what I want to tell you guys I'm taping
another stand-up special the first week
first weekend in March tickets are on
sale yet and I'm not naming the city yet
either cuz I gotta wait till live he
thinks all [ __ ] legally solidified
there and and I am now I am in drydock
once again I am off the booze that was
it I don't know what I'm gonna drink
again
maybe on my birthday in June I like I
had a great time drinking yesterday but
I am banged up
and I don't need to do that again for a
long time so I'm definitely not gonna
drink right up to this special and then
by then I'll have a good [ __ ] 60 days
in I'm let's go for a hundred days again
honey let's go for 200 then I'll try and
break my [ __ ] record 367 days in the
meantime I'll keep the weight off
I won't become Billie fat face that's
what it's all about I don't want to be
Billy fat face walking around oh look at
him there's a guy with dice cool look at
his face no I don't want to be that guy
I don't want to be a tub of [ __ ]
it's one of my big goals in life oh
speaking of which you guys make any New
Year's resolutions who's kidding who a
New Year's resolution is basically let's
see how long I can do this before I
going I go back to being the same
douchebag I was isn't that what they
really are you lie to yourself I'm
making a change you know
and maybe you can stick it out halfway
through February but by the beginning of
March what happens you look in the
mirrors you're brushing your teeth you
just yeah you're an [ __ ] starts
tomorrow tomorrow I get back on the
horse so that's it that's it I'm done
I'm done with the bows I'm done with the
booze maybe until the Rose Bowl next
year maybe that's what I'll do
once a [ __ ] year you know obviously
everybody knows that guy who owns a
[ __ ] Harley in their neighborhood and
once a year he gets a haircut in the
shave everybody no guy like that sure we
all do Deadeye Pete he's got some sort
of nickname you know maybe he killed
somebody maybe he didn't you know then
he had some weird really effeminate
thing about him you know like he could
literally choke a [ __ ] Sasquatch to
death yet he likes to finger paint or
something maybe that's what I'll do
maybe once a year I'm gonna drink it the
granddaddy of them all I don't know what
happened this year I really don't and I
don't understand how I so vividly
remember the game yet was completely I
don't remember the [ __ ] tailgate
whatsoever you know what sucks was for
the first year I missed the flyover I
was in the tunnel when the flyover
happened all these [ __ ]
in Wisconsin fans are [ __ ] walking
and waddling their way to their goddamn
seats I was rooting for Wisconsin this
year by the way oh by the way
congratulations to Oregon winning your
first Rose Bowl since 1917 that's
[ __ ] unbelievable
un-fuckin'-believable 95 i root it
against them because I didn't like their
snowglobe helmets just stupid you know
hologram come on you're a football team
or you know you're writing greeting
cards you know it's bad enough you
called the Ducks goddamn they were a
fast [ __ ] team Jesus Christ how many
times did somebody turn the corner and
you're thinking all right there's a six
yard gain and all sudden he's at 40 30
20 touchdown it's [ __ ] unreal did I
even stay in the stands during the yeah
it's all coming back to me I saw the
halftime show some band went out and did
a bunch of Van Halen songs you know cuz
nothing says van Halen like a hundred
piece [ __ ] Orchestra I actually got to
tell you I think it was Wisconsin that
did it there Wisconsin band that was the
only thing that sounded worse than when
David Lee Roth did the bluegrass version
of Van Halen songs but anyways and so
this is Christmas Christmas is over
everybody I want to ask you this have
you thrown out your tree yet don't you
always feel [ __ ] weird when you do
that
you get so excited for this [ __ ]
Christmas tree you know and then what
happens like this the day it's over you
just look at it like like it was in a
boy band and in it the Justin Timberlake
left and now you yeah you're just
looking at your Christmas tree like it's
Lance Bass and [ __ ] 2006 you know so
I actually pride myself in the way I
dispose of my Christmas tree every year
I do it the proper way I do it the way
he's supposed to
I don't just [ __ ]
and you know put it in the passenger
seat of my car like some [ __ ]
hitchhiker you met put two in the back
of its head you throw it out on the
[ __ ] medium strip of a highway I
don't do that I dispose of it like the
[ __ ] Iceman you know did you guys
ever see The Iceman when he talked about
cutting up the bodies that's what I do
get all the decorations all the jewelry
cut out the fillings you know and then I
take it out in the driveway and I
[ __ ] cut it up and I stick it in the
recyclable you know unlike my [ __ ]
neighbors who just take the whole tree
and stick it in the recycle bin good
thing sticking out stand-in there like
that [ __ ] old school Denver Broncos
fan that where's the barrel around his
waist that's the only thing it's missing
when you just take the whole Christmas
tree and you stick it in the barrel you
should just have some [ __ ] suspenders
going up and over attached on to it is
that what it should have bill oh I think
it should
all right let's read this is the Monday
morning podcast by the way everybody and
hey let's get down to some [ __ ] of
the [ __ ] here I've actually finally
figured out a way here to make some
money off the podcast do you guys go to
amazon.com sure we all do anytime you
guys go there if you'd like to make a
donation to my podcast rather than going
directly to amazon.com just go to
billboard.com
click on podcast I know this is a couple
extra steps all right and once you click
on the podcast you look on the
right-hand side of the page right under
where it says iTunes is amazon.com you
click right on there you go to Amazon
and you buy something doesn't cost you
any more money but I get I get a
percentage they give me a little bit
they give me a little kickback you go
bill don't tell nobody we gave this to
you right just for driving people
towards amazon.com so you're already
going there now you just go there
through my website you know and in that
way you get to donate to the podcast
without spending any [ __ ] money you
know I'm not telling you to go to
amazon.com and buy some
then you don't want to [ __ ] buy I'm
saying when you go there go through my
website click on the amazon.com and you
buy something and then 10% of whatever I
make I'm gonna give to the Wounded
Warriors Project so it's a way to
support this podcast and support the
troops and get yourself the [ __ ] I
don't know whatever the [ __ ] the
Radiohead anthology whatever the [ __ ]
you're buying over there who knows um oh
and speaking of that else have another I
have another sponsor ah what is it
stamps calm that's the latest one if you
go to stamps calm you know what I was
too drunk yesterday to try and [ __ ]
remember how this one goes I don't know
how this one goes I'll let you know
about it next week but it's basically
stamps calm you know what happens you go
down on the [ __ ] post-office you got
to stand in line to get stamps to go up
to one of those grumpy people that's
gonna end up shooting up the [ __ ]
place right what do they say going
postal there's a reason they say that
those [ __ ] people are dangerous down
there now I'm usually against that
automated [ __ ] all right
you know I don't like I don't like that
automated [ __ ] down at the grocery store
but those [ __ ] the goddamn people
behind the register don't shoot up the
[ __ ] grocery store every three
goddamn days alright but this [ __ ] you
know I [ __ ] hate the post office
they're a bunch of [ __ ] there I said it
you go down there you stand in the
[ __ ] line you stand there for 20
[ __ ] minutes you finally get up to
front just to buy a book of goddamn
stamps and the douche puts this windows
closed and then goes over and eats a
[ __ ] chicken salad sandwich where you
can see him
I [ __ ] hate those [ __ ] and I to the
point I actually started using the
automated machine down there it's
something else I don't [ __ ] like
because when you stand in line what it
where is it Oh automated machine is
gonna be so [ __ ] easy right no
there's some [ __ ] up there sending
out his Christmas cards to 400 [ __ ]
relatives he's got away packages and all
that [ __ ] and what's the problem there
he doesn't work at the post office he
doesn't know how to [ __ ] do it
but if you go to stamps.com everybody
you just [ __ ] bing bang boom you click
it you get some goddamn stamps and you
don't have to go down there and put your
life in jeopardy there
stamps.com everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
how is that for a read did you like that
well the hell's my computer alright it's
over here that might have been the
angriest commercial you're ever gonna
hear we liked what he was saying is he
could just not say it so angrily alright
last week I asked the ladies to justify
the divorce laws okay and you know what
not a goddamn one of them could [ __ ]
do it so for some reason some guy
decides to write in I was basically
saying justify to me justify to me just
to fighting me why Kobe Bryant's wife
deserves a hundred and ninety million
dollars justify it to me
don't say well cuz that's what the law
says don't say that justify the
reasoning for it
and I use the example if I asked you why
is it illegal to kill somebody you
wouldn't be like that's what the law
says you be like life is the most
precious thing on the planet we all need
to respect people's lives if you do not
respect somebody's live we can't just
have people go around taking other
people's lives away like their the Lord
alright
you could justify the reasoning for it
you know what and nobody can do it
including this douchebag this guy goes
bail here's why she deserves the money
and then he goes on and says marriage is
nothing more than a legal and/or
religious fiction that makes two people
partners Wow there's some new
information when two consenting adults
get married on there of their own free
will they are volunteering themselves
into an official partnership where both
parties agree that their lives and
assets are now shared equally unless
they agree on a prenup do you see the
difference here this guy's basically
do--it he's basically and in an
elaborate way gone that's left a lot
that he's not justifying it justify to
me why why does that law exist
I know why I shouldn't kill you I
shouldn't take your life for what you're
[ __ ] lit your life you get one of
them I shouldn't take it away
totally makes sense it's logical that we
can't have people going around killing
one another you know unless they're
evildoers but if you can't you can't on
anyway justify somebody getting a
hundred ninety million dollars of NBA
championship rings and they've never
even [ __ ] hit in the league
did she ever even play basket did no you
cannot logically tell me you can't you
can't justify it bait sir all you're
doing right now is you're telling me
what the [ __ ] law is I understand
what the law is I understand that I live
in California and if I get married and I
don't have a [ __ ] prenup okay she is
automatically entitled to half of my
[ __ ] she's entitled 1/2 much it doesn't
make sense though I'm telling you to
make sense of it don't tell me you're
basically going you know there's a law
in Alabama if you're in a car where the
girl is 17 she ain't got her shoes on
that statutory rape and then I go
justify that law to me why is hot what
where is the rape in that what is that
and if well with two consenting adults
get into a car and the one with the
[ __ ] takes her shoes off and she's 17
and under that's not justifying it then
he goes on to say why would any person
who's worth substantially more money
than the other agreed to such an
arrangement now you're just saying
Kobe's [ __ ] stupid for doing this
that's that's not my question Brad all
right he's goes and then he goes if Kobe
had suffered a career-ending injury when
he married his wife and then she went on
to win the Super Lotto and at a hundred
million dollars I guarantee Kobe would
want his split and he would deserve
every penny okay
why why would he deserve every penny
tell me why I'm not saying that he
wouldn't ask for it you're not answering
the [ __ ] question Brad answered
[ __ ] question why what you don't
[ __ ] deserve it you know you don't if
you go out and you marry the greatest
composer of all time and that person
composes this timeless [ __ ] music
that for [ __ ] centuries people are
gonna be listening to and analyzing a
ninja in during the course that you made
hundreds of millions of dollars okay I
understand why that person made hundreds
of millions of dollars I don't get why
if he then gets a divorce from somebody
who can just sit there on the couch
eating [ __ ] Doritos all day when they
get divorced why they're entitled to
half of the [ __ ] riches stop
explaining I know the law says that
that's why they should the law says that
they are legally entitled to I'm saying
what is the reasoning behind that okay I
get it you don't want a bunch of guys
going out starting families and then
[ __ ] walking away I understand that
but at some [ __ ] point
you have enough [ __ ] money she should
just write her a check for twenty
million dollars twenty million dollars
is more money than most people will ever
make in their [ __ ] lives most people
wouldn't won't even come close to that
in their [ __ ] lifetime will not come
close to that she's getting it all at
once you get twenty million dollars you
are set for [ __ ] life but that's not
enough for these [ __ ] they get a
hundred and ninety million dollars this
what [ __ ] kills me they they're worth
nine figures they haven't accomplished
anything in their life I understand why
Kobe is worth three hundred [ __ ]
million dollars you see this guy this
past week he's got a [ __ ] he's has an
injury that most people would have sat
out six months of the season this guy is
a [ __ ] warrior this is a Celtics fan
Santa that guy is a [ __ ] warrior okay
they don't make guys like that guys like
that come around once every two three
generations the guy is the [ __ ] man
and he is worth I understand why he's
worth thirty million dollars I for the
life of me do not understand I cannot
justify whatever the [ __ ]
says [ __ ] that law justify it for me you
can't do it you guys had an entire
[ __ ] week nobody can do it and one
guy named Brad basically just told me
what the law was but he did he didn't
justify it why does that law exist
why isn't there some sort of [ __ ] oh
shut up Hill we got it all right
this [ __ ] drives me up the [ __ ]
wall
he's [ __ ] goddamn bum ass [ __ ]
women can't even tie that goddamn shoes
are walking around multi-millionaires I
saw one time his [ __ ] lady she was
married to this guy in the NBA and the
guy [ __ ] a round on her and they get a
divorce yeah got a divorce okay yeah he
[ __ ] around yeah he [ __ ] up you know
and then she goes out takes all his
[ __ ] money and drives around in a car
with a license plate that says his money
I just think like this did the arrogance
and the self-entitled like I am entitled
oh you cheated on me therefore I'm
entitled to hundreds of millions of
dollars you're not you're not but you
are because that's what the law says
it's the stupidest [ __ ] thing ever
his money can you believe the arrogance
of that [ __ ] let me like him you knocked
your wife out you know your second wife
out and then you got a license plate
that said two for two you said two for
two and then every guy on TV was gone
that's right that's right
like totally back in it you [ __ ] bum
ass broads go out and get a [ __ ] job
go invent something earn you [ __ ]
money [ __ ] cheated on you of course
he did he's doing what he's supposed to
be doing you got a [ __ ] champion
racehorse what do they do yet does it go
out and [ __ ] one horse and that's it no
they sent it out to stud cuz it's got
that championship gene pumping through
his blood you know why there's so many
mouth-breathing fat [ __ ] on airplanes
because of the marriage laws cuz you
only can bang one of them and are great
ones with that [ __ ] thoroughbred
semen are supposed to stick with one
person au idea [ __ ] minds all right
that was ignorant and disgusting alright
let's plow ahead here okay the question
is still open still on
Table tell me why tell me why Kobe's
wife justify why she deserves a hundred
and ninety million dollars justify it
morally the way I can justify to you
morally why you can't you shouldn't kill
somebody why you shouldn't steal
somebody stuff I totally get all of that
I get all of that you know these same
[ __ ] broads who can't justify this
can justify morally why you a guy
shouldn't [ __ ] around on his wife they
would be like well cuz that's what the
law says they wouldn't they wouldn't
they would [ __ ] judge right off the
top of their [ __ ] heads could give you
a 20-minute speech and none of it would
have to do with the law it would all
have to do with love and trust and
relationships and they could morally
justify it this [ __ ] law there's not
a [ __ ] broad out there they are a guy
out there that can justify somebody who
sits around all goddamn day not doing
[ __ ] and then being entitled to a
hundred ninety million dollars of Los
Angeles Lakers championship money if you
had an alien land on this planet the
first question would be well does this
person play for the Lakers does she work
for them
did she draft the players did she design
the uniforms that what does she do any
this she really really and then that
would be any take out his little laser
gonna need shooter in the [ __ ] and that
would be it but sadly we don't live in a
world like that all right
advice for the week number one built my
wife and I are both workout people
triathlons half marathons etc you guys
are gonna get his and her hip
replacements and your [ __ ] early 60s
last year we started attending a class
I'll do this is [ __ ] up
I remember this one last year we started
attending a class to help with this to
help with this or working out and the
instructor seemed like a good [ __ ] we
got along great and he works for the
same company we do this is a huge
company and I'm not gonna say where so
it's not like he sits next to me or
something
anyway we really enjoyed this guy's
class and he would email all the people
that took the class regularly telling
him what they needed for that day's
class weights a mat jump rope etc it's
p90x oriented so since we were both on
the mailing lists we knew his email
address I started to seize things
happening
my wife was emailing him a lot he was
emailing her a lot it was a conversation
between them via work email which is
okay I guess but then they started
texting each other Oh Gigi and it was
frequent and come downstairs I hear a
phone snaps shut and I'd say who are you
talking to she would always say no one
or just checking my messages etc being
that I'm a system engineer and
Technology I called [ __ ] and
proceeded to capture her passwords on
the laptop downstairs Jesus Christ he
goes I know but I wanted to see what was
up so I got a password logged into her
phone account online and lo and behold
she was texting this guy back and forth
first of all dude how did you capture
her password this is why I don't bank
online I don't do any of that [ __ ] this
is the kids a secure site no it isn't um
anyways so he finds out that she's
texting this dude both of them are
texting back and forth and he says I'm
not just saying during the day a few
times I'm saying throughout the day and
up until 11 p.m. at night even after
midnight and while I'm lying in bed next
to her she would always get pissed if I
said anything about who the [ __ ] are you
talking to at 11 p.m. we became mutual
friends with this person from the start
and I asked some girls I knew and some
guys and some guys that I that both knew
him and they both said yeah you need to
address it so I called the dude one
night and pretty much said stop [ __ ]
texting my wife at night are you and I
are gonna have a problem any
we shut it down this guy's five seven
150 pounds and not some stud or anything
I'm six one 200 pounds and could easily
stomp his ass out
he's an endurance runner not some super
jack guy he immediately stopped and
every time I saw him in the locker room
of the gym he was very cautious around
me and way too nice almost like it was
his way of saying sorry everything
stopped after that my question is was I
right doing this addressing it with him
basically texting has blurred the lines
between what's okay and what's not guys
and girls always say oh it was just a
text but no big deal but I think it
that's horseshit it's this it's the same
as a phone call to me so if you want to
call my wife while I'm in bed with her
go for it but they won't texting is a
[ __ ] move which is why so many people
get busted doing it if they were with me
want to even email each other at work
and discuss workout routines I get it
but having that instant connection
through your phone no matter where they
are is a little odd especially while I'm
in bed right next to her am I wrong for
putting this [ __ ] in line and telling
him to stop it yeah dude you know what
the only reason why you're asking me if
you're wrong is because you busted your
[ __ ] wife and right now she's mine
[ __ ] you manipulating you trying to
get you she and she's basically almost
done it almost flipped it around you're
actually questioning am i [ __ ] wrong
for [ __ ] catching my wife texting
with this other guy at 11 o'clock at
night there's only one reason you text
somebody at 11 o'clock at night two
reasons either you ran out of gas are
you trying to [ __ ] him that's the only
two reason people text at that [ __ ]
hour than though he's trying to [ __ ]
your wife all right and I don't know
what's up with your wife okay cuz you're
going who you texting Oh nobody right
there the fact that she goes oh nobody
and slams the [ __ ] phone shot right
there
she knows she's doing something that
ain't [ __ ] cool
this is a very [ __ ] touchy subject
all right because this involves the
woman cheating and guys solve problems
with violence so I'm not trying to [ __ ]
an egg you on here sir but you
definitely did the right thing and
that's really a what the [ __ ] situation
that you're in that ain't [ __ ] cool
all right I'm gonna step outside of your
situation now sir all right other than
say that you 100% did the right thing
and do not let her [ __ ] worm her way
out of it all right personally speaking
now now I'm talking about me I'm
stepping away from this story if I
caught my girl doing it that's a [ __ ]
wrap it's over the relationship is
[ __ ] over go [ __ ] yourself all right
it's over it's over I know where the
[ __ ] this is going I know where the hell
this is leave what the [ __ ] eat X this
guy for 11 o'clock at night you want to
suck his dick why what was he telling
how to do the perfect jumping jack at
11:30 at night he couldn't tell you that
if for he has to email you text you
[ __ ] 9000 times during the course of
the day to tell you how to do a [ __ ]
pushup
give me a [ __ ] break you're flirting
with this guy you want to [ __ ] him
so relationship is over
happy [ __ ] bum buddy de bomba dee de
bomba dee de right happy trails to you
get the [ __ ] out of here it's over
that's that's that's how you got to
handle that thing the same way [ __ ]
Kobe's wife when she busted him cheating
rather than taking that big Tweety Bird
diamond that she got from him she's
right there the relationship it's
[ __ ] over it's [ __ ] over trust is
gone it's [ __ ] over but he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars which
for some reason she's entitled to half
of it so she stuck around she stuck
around put in her 10 years now he has to
pay for her [ __ ] life for the rest of
her life he has to [ __ ] support her
like she's a goddamn child and it's
legal
somebody please justify that I'll never
get over at people I'll keep going back
to it till one of you [ __ ] can
morally justified the reasoning behind
that [ __ ] law please stop wasting my
time by telling me what the law is in
speculating well the tables were flipped
Kobe what had done it I'm not saying who
would have done what I'm saying
morally tell me the reasoning behind
that [ __ ] law okay the only thing I
can think of is that back in the day
guys would start families and then jump
on the horse and say I'm [ __ ] out of
here and they just left and then you had
this poor woman with four kids and they
were in poverty I get that you want to
[ __ ] avoid that okay if that's what
the justify if you're gonna try and
justify it that way I get it but what I
would like to introduce is it is a a new
modification of that law where there's
some sort of salary cap okay I don't
think just because you married somebody
who's rich man a woman that that gives
you the [ __ ] right to sit on your
goddamn ass for the rest of your [ __ ]
life and get arrogant license plates
saying his money her money I didn't pay
for it hahaha I mean right there you
wonder why people get killed that's the
kind of [ __ ] right there that's two
minutes for instigating right there if
he comes over and [ __ ] slaps the
goddamn spit out of your mouth what did
you do it look at her license plate your
honor yeah you know what that makes
sense the [ __ ] is wrong with you what do
you have that license plate for that's
not how it works I don't care that she's
being a [ __ ] that's no excuse for
treating her like one
all right advice number two dear bill um
bill I made you after show in Pittsburgh
the black guy with the hot latina and we
laughed about my shoes matching my
outfit well my beautiful girlfriend for
the past three years has a little bit of
insecurity insecurity issues a lot of
those absolutely gorgeous women do you
know why it is it's because their level
I'm without even reading this [ __ ] the
reason why I think a lot of them are
[ __ ] insecure is because because
they're beautiful
and that goes away after a while so the
clock is just [ __ ] ticking you know
if you just some regular douchebag like
me there's no pressure going back to
your [ __ ] high school reunion I mean
there's the expectations is so [ __ ]
low you know it's easy to surpass him
like yeah jeez he didn't get fed this
guy's awesome but if you're a [ __ ]
hot chick it can just it can only go
downhill and I also think that they have
the same insecurities a rich guy has
where rich guys like this woman's just
with me because of my money not because
of Who I am
I think that they have the insecurities
that this person is just with me because
of my ass today Hayes hi all right for
summary odd reason she feels the need
for me to prove to her that I love her
whenever we're in a public setting
so recently during some Christmas
shopping she got upset that I wouldn't
hold her hand as we walk through the
mall she proceeded to catch one of the
one of her spicy Latin attitudes with me
see now if you were white and you said
that and you said that on TV
you would have to apologize for nine
weeks when you would lose your job why
does it have to be spicy are you saying
that Latino people are like their
peppers all right I'm gonna stop
commenting and just plow through this
okay so I handle handle the situation
like a G parentheses gentleman and
completely ignored her ass until we got
into the car and I finally had enough of
her telling me how I don't love her and
how she wants me to love her oh I don't
love her how she wants me to love her
and how unaffectionate of a man I am and
you know what dude that right there is
probably how you got this hot girl
because you weren't the first guy
sitting there with your tongue hanging
out of your mouth you acted like you
didn't even give a [ __ ] which fed into
her insecurities of like oh my god is
the expiration date hit am I not hot
anymore
look at me commenting again all right I
swear these [ __ ] are so on a preachy
I'm appreciative this is funny you call
them [ __ ] why can't these [ __ ]
understand how much I appreciate
yes every weekend bill we do something
dinner movies plays etc but because she
has a vag she has to find something to
complain about I think it's because
women have this trait where they feel a
strong need to be miserable no dude you
know what's going on is you're spoiling
her you're taking it to dinner movies
plays every [ __ ] weekend she now
she's come to expect it you know what I
mean
it's just become part of a routine it's
not special anymore so now you have to
do something extra special because
special isn't special you know that's
what I do you know what I got to whisper
this [ __ ] we were up in San Francisco
right I lit up my credit card says
Christmas all right my girl had a great
[ __ ] Christmas all right it's three
days later we're up in [ __ ] San
Francisco she wants to go shopping I'm
like for what you didn't get enough you
know so she knows I'm right so what does
she do she tells me she wants a goddamn
candle okay cuz it's not expensive but
she'll still feel like she got something
because I don't know what it is they
always got a feed they always got to get
stuff there's always got to be some sort
of a goodie bag and you know what I
wouldn't get it for I wouldn't get it
for okay you're done no I'm not it's
over my credit cards are still glowing
I'm not getting you [ __ ] and you know
she's cool as hell so she just kept
laughing because I was being
unbelievably rude and I was being really
loud I was just joking around and but
still that's the thing and I just kept
saying I spoil you um you know we're
shutting it down for a while you're not
getting anything until Valentine's Day
you know you want something now get you
a little bag of Fritos what do you think
about that maybe something to wash it
down with and then what they do is they
immediately get mad and then all you do
is you don't take the bait they want you
to get mad so then they can turn it into
a fight about something else cuz they
know you're [ __ ] right alright so let
it be mad all you gotta do it you're
just gonna stay [ __ ] calm well let's
see what this guy does huh
so anyways he goes so we are driving
along the highway leaving them all
and she's still bitching and finally I
tell her you know what if you don't like
the way I express my love for you then
step off gotta read that quote like a
black man I can't I'm not even gonna try
to so immediately yeah I actually read
that I read that like a douchey East
Coast what guy did [ __ ] step off how
did you [ __ ] how was that was that good
I know it wasn't but they don't ask me
to do it
alright flying ahead you know what I
might have like a [ __ ] substitute
black guy for when black guys write some
[ __ ] in here so you guys can read it the
way you're supposed to say it other than
that you're getting [ __ ] a cracker
ass read you're gonna have to live with
it alright so immediately after that I
said after I said that this [ __ ] starts
throwing these accurate and quick ass
Pacquiao combos she's punching you mind
you I'm doing 65 miles per hour down the
highway trying not to hit the guardrail
while at the same time getting this
crazy [ __ ] off me luckily I didn't
crash my year-old Mercedes this guy's
hilarious come on do do you love this
girl is she just another accessory my
year-old Mercedes with the Corinthian
leather
I get pulled over get pulled over a god
forbid seriously injure us I mush the
hell out of her and held her face
against the passenger window totally
acceptable totally the mush is the
gentleman move you can't punch her you
just hold her head up against the glass
you know so the people on the other side
get to see what her face looks at a
funhouse mirror in order to decrease her
reach while steering the car on the
highway and absorbing her manly combos
got to give it to her the [ __ ] had a
mean right so if you could picture me
driving I can totally picture this dude
I've lived this so you can picture me
driving down the highway and a bright
red Mercedes okay not I didn't never had
a Mercedes it was more than a eith 83
Ford Ranger with black vinyl seats
[Laughter]
um swerving like some drunk in and out
of lane
staring with one hand and stiff-arming
the [ __ ] out of my girl as if I'm posing
for the Heisman Trophy after she stopped
beating my face and she had the nerve to
say I hit her and hurt her worse by
pressing her face against the glass are
you [ __ ] kidding me
this [ __ ] almost took both of our lives
long story short as soon as I was able
to come to a safe and complete stop I
kicked the [ __ ] out and haven't heard
from her since this was three weeks ago
and it's all for the best that type of
girl can never be satisfied which is
something I've learned the hard way over
the past three years but this was the
straw that did it so my question for you
is was I wrong in this situation and do
I owe her an apology no and no all right
all you can do is break down your game
plan all right this is what you [ __ ]
up you took the bait all right she kept
bitching and bitching and bitching and
bitching trying to make you mad she was
trying she got you to do exactly what
she wanted you to do so that gave her a
an excuse to do what she wanted to do
which was [ __ ] flip out and yell
alright that's what they do when they
know they don't have a [ __ ] leg to
stand on and they know they're wrong
what they then try to do you know not
all of them and not in every situation
but when then they're not gonna be an
adult and just say you know what you're
right I'm being [ __ ] crazy right now
I apologize okay
when they're not gonna take that adult
route what they then do is they just
push your buttons and they just try to
make you mad and they just keep pushing
you and pushing it and pushing it and
pushing it until you then flip out and
say something [ __ ] crazy like well if
you don't like it then why don't you get
the [ __ ] out and then they flip out
alright so what you got to do is in the
future is you just don't take the bait
you got to recognize you know they're
doing they're doing the [ __ ] Dennis
Rodman thing to you the baton you into a
penalty that's all they're doing
okay and the ref always sees the
retaliation that's basically it's the
same [ __ ] thing so in the future just
don't get mad it will drive them up the
[ __ ] wall and you won't believe the
amount of arguments you're gonna start
winning because in their effort to piss
you off they're gonna cross like ten of
the lines all right now when they cross
ten of the lines if you take the bait
and then go even further down the road
that's all that's remembered in the end
as you then try and piece together who
said what when but if they go if they
cross ten lines and you don't take the
bait they had ten lines beyond where the
[ __ ] they should be and you got him dead
to rights and you just have to maintain
your [ __ ] cool now getting back to
this other [ __ ] is you do not owe her a
[ __ ] apology all right
it's absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous it's
absolutely childish and you can't as an
adult expect somebody to not hit you if
you're hitting them alright she's
basically asking you to extend a common
human-to-human courtesy that she's not
extending to you so she can go [ __ ]
herself you definitely I don't know if
you made the right move now I don't know
if you walk around calling her a [ __ ]
and that type of thing this is you just
trying to be a tough guy going then this
[ __ ] said this and this you know this
[ __ ] said that that's another thing
don't go around calling up [ __ ] cuz
that's it that just kills your argument
don't have a call on bad names alright
just hold your ground
don't lose your [ __ ] cool and let
them go through their whole little
[ __ ] histrionics trying to get you to
take the [ __ ] bait alright and as
long as in the relationship you admit
when you're wrong and you sincerely
apologize they don't have a [ __ ] leg
to stand on when you're right and you're
gonna start winning arguments and you're
gonna be happier there you go alright
another than that I don't know stop
dating psychos alright here we go
YouTube videos of the week
drumming mom kills wipeout I haven't
seen that but that's a classic drumming
song
an angry Kid with bo staff you got to
see this kid I think Bruce Lee came back
as a little blonde-haired white kid I
don't know what but this kid is tapping
into Bruce Lee's fighting force and I'm
telling you you could [ __ ] take over
a small country with three of the three
kids like this that's it
Oh dilemmas real quick bill one would
you rather get your ass kicked by a
flaming homosexual male or a raging bull
dyke woman that's tough can I say both
because both would be [ __ ] hilarious
a raging bull you know an a raging bull
dyke woman that's not as funny as a
flaming homosexual man if I got like you
know the Hollywood stereotype like oh my
god I'm gonna kick your ass I would
rather have that just because that would
be [ __ ] now what am I talking about
look for this for them for the hilarity
of people around me I would rather have
it be a flaming homosexual male but for
my [ __ ] ego a raging bull dyke woman
because Italy because at least I could
have the excuse of well I didn't want to
hit a woman didn't want to hit a woman
you couldn't you and knocked out you
[ __ ] and then I could I could just
you know I could go into some rant about
society um anyways number two hey Bill
should I bang my co-workers girlfriend
who is allergic to rubbers and as three
baby daddies or remain a 29 year old
virgin
all right that's ones [ __ ] that
doesn't exist if you're twenty-nine year
old virgin you don't know how to get
[ __ ] laid and you would never have
that [ __ ] conversation with somebody
pre sex you know talking about condoms
[Music]
so I'm not gonna answer that one but
just in case it's true should I bang my
co-workers girlfriend no you shouldn't
bang your co-workers girlfriend you're
[ __ ] with your ability to have a job
pay your bills and eat who's allergic to
rubbers no you don't wanna get okay you
get you're gonna get some genital warts
out of that that that'll be the least of
your [ __ ] problems or remain a 29
year old virgin remain
a 29 year old virgin sir why don't you
go to 29 year old virgin calm and find
some other 29 year old virgin and you
guys put on [ __ ] raincoats and have
at it why don't you do that all right
that really wasn't a dilemma that was
more advice that's the podcast for this
week Happy New Year everybody and like I
said if you want to go to amazon.com if
you're gonna buy some please go through
my website click on the merchandise
button click on then click on the Amazon
thing you'll give me some money for the
podcast you'll donate to the podcast and
10% of it goes to the Wounded Warriors
Project and that's it that is the
podcast you know what I haven't done a
long time I haven't hiked any of my
[ __ ] dates let's see where's old
Billy fat face gonna be oh I just
belched I got [ __ ] hot burn events I
am gonna be the next dates I have
January 20th I'm gonna be at the House
of Blues in Houston Texas January 21st
I'm gonna be at the Paramount Theater in
Austin Texas and then we're into
February February I'll be in Charlotte
North Carolina Alabama Birmingham and
Atlanta Georgia that's like the week of
February 8th I'm gonna get those dates
up today hopefully if my agent is back
from [ __ ] vacation I'll get the
actual dates which he already gave me
and I [ __ ] up and after that I'll be
February 17th at the Fox Theatre in
Connecticut at Foxwoods in the Bergen PA
see Center in Englewood New Jersey
theater at Westbury Westbury New York
look at that look at that oh and there
it is Lincoln Lincoln theater Lincoln
Theatre I actually already have it up
March 3rd Washington DC that's where I'm
taping my special this secret is out
that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any
[ __ ]
happy goddamn New York
you